hello and welcome everyone we have our
trainer winnowed will be starting
today's session and before we go ahead
and let let me explain you a couple of
important points before we start the
session everyone will be on mute this is
to avoid the background noise you have
any question please do put your question
in the chat window so that we can
respond to it however I advise you to
reserve your questions for the last 15
minutes we will be having a question and
answer session 15 minutes so I'll be
here acting with a trainer
we are chat however you can post your
queries on the chat window so that we
can take it up the last section so 45
minutes from now the trainer will be
providing his inputs and I hope you are
able to see the screen of our trainer
and we can go ahead and start the
session we note we can get started now I
know you have any question you can put
it in chat I will be responding it to
you however as I say stead we will have
15 minute session at the end to answer
any queries coming in from the
participants all right so I'll get
started so I welcome one and all for
this program today and today we will be
covering a very interesting topic which
is inside the word hacking and I would
not be talking more of a theoretical
perspective per se I would be trying to
address more of the concerns on how
hackers make use of the hacking
techniques and how they exploit existing
waller please and try to gain access to
certain confidential data etcetera all
right so having in mind that this
program is planned to be a 1/2 - then I
will however close this program by 9:30
right it was from 8:30 to 9:30 so
effectively we have another 45 - 15
minutes now so going forward
I just will set the picture clear so the
first half an hour I will be giving a
little on theory and what we'll be
covering and trying and I will try to
set the base between us here and the
rest of the half the program we will be
seeing some very interesting hands-on
live demos so it would be great if you
are all interactive we know as
interactive as possible
so the session would become better all
right so you have the chat option
available so you can post your questions
on the chat if you have any I would be
more than happy to address it all right
so let me get started so I would want to
define the world's most secure system
this way the world's most secure system
is a system that is dug 10,000 miles
underground surrounded by 10,000 volts
of rectify defenses filled with toxic
nitrous gases in all sides with a bunch
of trained army men and I'll tell you it
also still stays one of the most
vulnerable piece of systems on the
internet yeah so I'm sure not a lot of
you'd agree to this but this is what
actually happens all right
yeah when I see this I also get reminded
of the very interesting saying the
saying is like this they say there there
are only two types of people in the
whole world just two types of people
number one the person who knows their
hat and two the person who does not know
their hat for him so effectively both of
it means that we either where's our hat
all right I am sure most of you
attending this program currently all
they do build that you are not tagged
and you have never been happy
it should know you know I'm sure you
have the questions yourself but if you
think of that they also say ignorance is
it this there is not of a situation
where we actually do not even know and
we have got hat a here all right okay
I'm sure a lot of you use Yahoo look at
this
Yahoo hack 4.5 black passwords posted
online well during 4.5 black passwords
posted online foreign reporter sage
email hacked in China I'm sure at least
80% of the crowd here use Google to
check or Google to search the internet
tonight I'll do you rest 20 percentage
of the Internet users use Google to
check if the internet is working
properly
yes so I'm sure most of you already
accept to this so 80 percentage of them
use Google to search the internet at
least 20 percentage of them moves to
check if that internet is working
properly look at the kind of trust and
the faith that the company has built
over the period of time that we when we
used Google to check if the Internet is
working properly
you know so that is the kind of trust
that the company has built over the time
can I ask you this quick question you
can all think of this question when do
you think Gmail got hack the last when
was the last time Google got hack google
recently got hacked six days ago yeah
Google got hat six days ago and
increasingly you know when Google got
hacked before that it got hadn't done
before there all right so effectively
Google has got hacked a couple of times
already
all right okay now FTP access on a sub -
yo Tom okay I would want to tell you
this this is very interesting I'm sure
most of you will be knowing what is a
self yes there is a very popular
computer peripheral manufacturing
company in the world right they are in
fact tied to computers for HP IBM then
Lenovo etc and imagine this there was an
actor who managed to
gain access to the FTP of a sir -
eurocom I repeat now attacker managed to
gain access to a sin - eurocom of FTP a
big FTP access of a sir - eurocom and
look this if you can find this there's a
zip file in the screenshot Craig there's
a zip file that you can find in the
screenshot here which clearly says and
I'm just marking it here oh can you see
that it says country-wise customer data
right it says country-wise customer data
so something very interesting here is
that the attacker has no only trying to
manage to you know gain access to the
FTP account but also to then tile
database dump of the entire web site and
you know what in any given website any
given website you will have a footer
column in a header column correct footer
and header column so what happened is in
the footer column attacker gave a link
which says download customer data
imagine that imagine you go to a website
and when you go to the website you see
your option alright you find our option
which is download my customer data how
cool that will be managed to do that and
something that attacker did was you know
something that the attacker did was then
I went in click on that option which
says download the customer data it gave
me a pop up message it's saying do you
want to download the customer data in
PDF file or an excel file
how cool is not right and an attacker is
very innovative and he applies all his
ideas in the way he wants right and he
otherwise calls it proof of concept
great ok
okay look at this I would want all of
you to pay attention to this this is a
very interesting slide right look at
this if you can notice here I'm sure
most of you would be ordered in doing
Casper's cake what is Casper scale what
is Casper sky expert ski is a popular
computer antivirus company in the world
right so what does this antivirus
company do they are there to set your
end users like you and me not to get hot
or not to get infected okay so once I
have a antivirus software installed in
my system it means that I have taken
enough steps to make sure I do not get
infected with that into it with the
virus correct so something that's very
interesting here is an attacker manages
to do an attack where it is called the
sequel injection right if you notice in
the address bar of this screenshot that
I'm showing you today I'm sure you can
see a screenshot great so in the
screenshot there is an option which
clearly tells you you have got Kaspersky
calm slash support something and you
have a long address on the URL bar
correct so what an attacker does here is
very interesting so what he what they do
is they say they are trying to pass in
some kind of a malicious crafted query
right this query is effectively going to
reply back with some sensitive data for
an example say I go and ask someone say
I I go and ask a bump see Annan alright
I see vamsi a man's name there right so
know that Denise Sam I'm going and
making ones here and in our opinion hi
is your name onion what did he reply he
would say is correct but what if I do
not ask him is an email and what if I
ask him hey
what would you reply he would say no my
name is Vamsi an incorrect
so effectively did I ask his name no I
just asked is your name Kumar
effectively he has to reply yes or no
right so what happens is it gives a
possibility for an end-user to gain some
more insight information about the
particular in the destination system
correct so look at this if this scale in
this case it is exactly what has
happened right so what happens here
attacker talks to Kaspersky's becomes
official there try it saying hey your
password is 1 2 3 it says no no my
password is Kaspersky so not what do you
understand so that is how attackers
tried to talk to computers then it is
look at this this very interesting
massive ATM card Hackett's Indian banks
3.2 me and debit cards affected I am
sure most of you already have read this
information and I will tell you I have
tried to collect some information which
is not real good these are all very new
information and Hakeem won one and half
month old information that is all right
ok look at this loopholes in banking
application 25 billion dollar could have
been stolen all right so I would want to
tell you all this in any information
security or any kind of ethical hacking
related the slides that you see whenever
there is a message to you saying that
could have being stolen it means that it
has happened all right it is not could
have it has happened you understand what
I'm saying
all right so look phones and biking up
25 billion dollars could have been
stolen Indian hackers finds flaw that
could let anyone steal twenty five
billion dollars from a bank how
interesting
look at this all accounts hacked credit
card accessed company says there was no
data breach how interesting is that look
at the first line and look at the second
line they are totally contradicting each
other right
Oobleck abs height and the attacker has
put a proof of concept of this attack
along with some confidential data on
disk block right and the company claims
that they will no such breached which
probably means that the attacker has
managed to gain access into the database
of a company and he made it he made the
attack in such a concise manner that
they'll attack you in totally undetected
he said no this was also a sequel
injection based attack right I got CDC
website hack information about 1.1 crore
people feared stolen I am sure you are
able to relate it now when it says
figured stolen it simply means it has
got stolen
all right okay now try website hat how
interesting it releases all email
addresses I'm sure you know most of you
have read this information already right
look at this at least 50 IT companies in
Hyderabad
had attacked my Pakistani hackers
something happening out there on the
Internet
yes look at this India's leading payment
gateway CC Avenue hacked and the
attacker not only just did that he also
the database was identified as mssql
storing passwords in plain text how cool
is that look at that I could manage to
take risks ensured and put it on his
blog website of ISRO
high reportedly by Chinese hackers see
these days attackers or do not really do
everything for money they do something
for
that attention you know grabbing that
attention from the end-users redness dot
I in database possibly hacked now you
all tell me what has possibly hacker
mean wait I'm sure you are related now
right thirteen point seven two GB of
user data on dark net okay I am not sure
if you have heard of this Israeli in
resonance
email account was compromised and his
email was uploaded on torrents for
downloaded can you imagine that right so
this is also very similar to that later
look at how much confidential
information gets to public hands like
this one eighty Indian company suffered
from ransomware attacks so far this year
okay let me ask you a quick question or
last before here do you know what is a
ingest most malware infected web site
you know in 2013 eeeh 2013 what is
India's most malware infected web site
to your notice it is State Bank of India
account alright there's a very clear
indication of what kind of a man you are
applause what was it trying to do how
did it find methods to infect the
visitors who came in access a site what
does a drive-by download attack
everything is documented in certain
blogs you might want to do some Google
search on that it's very interesting
alright okay look at this
Indian top celebrity IP accounts hacked
by a 22 year or 22 year old look at this
celebrity accounts who wear hat I feel a
bunny suction generator what have you
seen Donny Salman Khan Shahrukh Khan
these accounts were already hacked look
at the next screenshot I've managed to
get this was like yesterday's news
hackers accessed Ramadan these Twitter
account and the attacker also managed to
access is account using our proxy
chaining attack which means that the
would be jumping from various countries
alright so the I to track back over five
different countries so they were not
able to try to who that occur was look
at the next message Shashi Tharoor sorry
folks my Twitter account has been hacked
will be temporally deactivated wow I
just am not even here to comment on all
this but I'm just telling you I'm just
putting the situation to you upfront and
perfect right look at the kind of
distribution of attacks that are
happening right the major kind of an
attack you can just look at this for
your statistical purpose but now let us
quickly jump on to some hands-on because
we are running out of time
right okay now I want you all to open up
this domain emphasize Norcom / emc / IP
dot HTML okay I'll just open it for your
information on my system also please pay
attention what do you see here you see
what do you see you see your private IP
address I want you all to understand I
go to command prompt i say IP config
when I say IP conflict
it gives me an IP address detail what is
this this is my ipv4 wireless IP address
which is my LAN IP address which is not
a public IP address which is a private
IP address right it is 192 168 220 5.21
and look at this how interesting is this
and look I did not run any scripts I
have not done anything right and I'm not
unsure if you are you can just go to
this URL right you can just go to this
URL I have just created a script and
posted it there so then you just
accessing that will actually help me
understand your private IP as well not
just public IP but also your private IP
address wait I'm sure you all know that
of your cat this can be
taken right away you know I'll just go
to IP chicken calm or some website like
that it will quickly grab my public IP
and just post it back to me correct but
what is happening to me here I am just
not only getting your public happy but
also your private IP no I have just
written this small script so you can
understand not just a public at it but
also private IP could be gotten access
to say for an example I asked you all to
access this name which means that
there's effective chances that I can
even gain access to possibly mapping
your internet network right I will be
able to understand what is the network
topology what is the kind of you know
setup you have inside your internet as
well using these kind of scripts right
okay now number one number two is I will
also show you a small little tool that
we have developed ok so this tool I'm
just going to use any website of your
choice all right let me open up top
simply learn dot-com okay I'll just open
simply learn calm and it is going to
take some time or the calling to happen
let us give it some time
all right okay why that mean time let me
explain him once again so what we did
was we quickly saw in introduction then
we saw history of some attacks then not
be a same IEP enumeration great so what
happens in this IP dimension is add then
I just make you go to this world I get
access not only to know your public IP I
also get to know to your private IP so
in this case I already have information
about your IP addresses right
number two - III go to IP chicken
dot-com in IP chicken comm I get to know
my public IP address am i clear
so my publicly reachable IP address I
already know
now with this I can go to IP - location
comm / demo correct I want you all to
note this IP location okay so I put type
leprous here and say search this would
probably give us some kind of
information saying from where what I
Peters and some more information about
that particular IP address they
understand so this is a kind of an
enumeration which gives a little more
inside to us about the particular IP
correct okay let me quickly open up this
this script is running now
so by this mean time I will okay now
what we just saw was IP address and
enumerating it right so we saw what site
address internet IP address and internet
IP address and we also have seen how I
can actually log it on the back end
right so this now what we will be doing
is I'm gonna show you something called
the fullscreen API attack right so there
are three topics that we'll be covering
so the next topic will be a full screen
API attack right so before that I am
just going to show you this see this is
the application that we managed to
design all right so interestingly it
gives a lot of information about or
simply learn website to me right and
look at this this is something that I
wanted to show you right now I actually
ran script from my server do it can
comes my side okay from
this I am able to gain access to
understand and what all suppliers are
running on their own system I get to
know that Apache server is running on
simply a simply learn is running on an
Apache simply learn is also running a
maze on route 53 and I also get to know
their MX record details right and I also
know what SSL certificates they are
using where they are hosting today and
let us see little more interesting
information framework we clearly know
that it is a PHP if that is running on
now simply learn they are also using the
Perl framework and interestingly simply
learn looks like they are using Google
remarketing as their advertisement or I
know a plugin and they use all of these
analytics plugins and let us see little
more JavaScript and look at this these
kind of information gone to wrong hands
can actually he make them focus and
target what they would want to do right
if an attacker wants to attack a whole
system he has to know little more
information about the remote system
correct so this would be probably the
first few steps for an attacker right
okay so we are done with enumeration let
quick enumeration now let me go to
another website
okay now there's a very interesting
attack that I'm going to show you to
have one more demo and I think we will
have to close my line that if five
Rangers will like extend it for five or
or six more minutes to accommodate one
more demo so we'll have three demos at
once right you want to notice this
address bar which you can find here all
right I want you to pay attention this
part right please pay attention to this
area this area you will be able to find
the status bar right so I want you to
pay attention here when I take my mouse
and put the mouse here correct what do
you find do you find the okay do you
find the URL saying HTTP colon www dot
thank of AmeriCorps calm on the bottom
left you find that rate which means that
when you go click on this it opens up or
it opens up the Bank of America or cons
link it's all ooh correct okay now let
us see what happens I am just going to
clip that right what has happened what's
happened I just clicked on it and opened
up this page I'm able to browse through
the page etc correct and I also notice
that the SSL certificate is their impact
correctly
thing is intact right now I want you to
know that what you're seeing here right
whatever you seen here it's interesting
you not that of America right look at
this it is a fist page and whatever you
are seeing here everything is a snuffed
image right let me explain you what I'm
sure most of you would have gone to
youtube.com right in YouTube player on
the bottom right there is a maximize
button right then you are watching a
video and click that maximize button it
achieved the face of the entire scene
the way vo fills up the entire screen
correct it so no so that is actually
called the fullscreen API that is being
called it is a html5 API right so what
happens is that particular API makes the
video become a full screen video okay so
via we use the same API on to this
particular demo right look at this I
press escape button on my system and it
goes back to this page now I take my
mouse here and when I click on this it
opens up a page which looks exactly like
Bank of America right so what have we
taught in debt I know we get emails from
banks like I say sh t FC ID BC and oil
saying do not click links that come from
unsolicited emails etcetera right why is
that because it is rest assured that
there might be phished emails they might
be spams which will try to a victim and
or share your username and passwords to
attackers right
look at this they also tell very clearly
done you should look for sites which has
a HTTPS right HT symbol and all look at
this as end-user I go put my mouse here
on my left bottom it says
bankofamerica.com I go click here
beautiful
is this a ticket so it simply means that
it doesn't even look like a fist page
right so they're high chances and
attacker can fit you know fetch
potential details from end users look at
this this is what I say let me mark it
this this this is what you find in the
YouTube option great so okay so are we
not able to follow yes so let me quickly
say fishy okay so by when I click on
this what happens it is a page that I
have hosted all right which means that
any data inside this page and custom
modify or modified by me so I will
create a page which looks like Eisley I
see a bank or HDFC Bank in this case it
is Bank of America right so I give you
this page and you click on it you type
your username password I get to get your
username and password to me you name
them correct so it is a fished page that
I have created with which I will be able
to get your username and password right
even though you try to look if it is
HTTP page it is HTTP page it looks
exactly like that alright so this is the
second demo that I wanted to show you
right so we actually absolute the most
or two demos one as though in
enumeration I just showed you the quick
little truth that I ran to get
information about what all is run on the
what all plugins are run on the remotes
ok remote destination system and also we
happen to see we are able to get the
internal private IP address also right
ok now
we have a Buddha or seven minutes for
efficient clothes in the program but we
might extend it a little more first now
so I HP one model us demo and this demo
okay so I am actually showing you demo
but demonym one was the enumeration who
was a can see enumeration where we saw
location checked using IP to location
calm all right and we also saw what
plugins are running right so you know
this is just to give you a quick brief
iran and demo class we will get in
detail on the actual course as such
right so second one you saw is a
phishing phishing attack right so in
fishing what does a end-user do he tries
to create a look-alike page of the
actual site and try to get user name and
passwords at Intel divine end users so
that he can steal it tonight so that is
phishing attack okay number three now
let us go for memory based attack this
memory and we will close for the day all
right okay what what am I gonna do with
memory right let me use gmail for a
quick example here right I close every
instance of all the other running
applications in my system so that
everything looks very clean to you okay
okay now I will just open up oops
okay I'm assuming that you're all able
to see in my screen right let me confirm
that yeah okay so let me see look at
this I will just first put the scenario
clear and then show you a quick example
here all right
the scenario is very simple I want you
want to pay attention very important
okay number one I am sure most of you go
to your office or your universities or
anybody at you who you know due to your
gmail account right you type in your
username you type in a password right
and you use it for the entire day you
log then you send out emails you receive
in emails you chat with friends do
everything right and then end of there
what do you do is you click sign hope
the log over correct I'm sure who all of
you do this today logged in to the
particular account correct okay so I am
going to consider such a scenario here I
want all of you to assume that that the
mood I am showing you is is one of the
systems where there is someone okay
public system where someone is using the
system logging in wait he types in are
using it types in a password logs in
checks the email logs out and goes off
alright so assume that is the normal
procedure right now let me introduce
attacker here assume I am an attacker
right I would want to gain access to the
person who used the computers password
okay but there are other techniques
where attackers would want to install a
Trojan or backdoor a keylogger these are
different techniques in which an
attacker might want to gain access to
our users account username passwords
right but in
this scenario assume we do not have any
such information or assume we did not
install anything to the computer right
so which means that there is no software
that is running that will record the
keystrokes nothing all right so this is
the situation I have I put the situation
clear to you right now let me show you
experiment of how you would be able to
see if the data can be read out all
right let me use a live example with my
own right username and password do not
change my password after this demo
because you know I probably get an SMS
alert anyway so I'll type in my email id
right okay excellent in this case I
typed in my password all right I want
all of you to pay attention I've just
logged into my gmail account all right
so I have a lot of messages etc exit on
and what I'm going to do is I II am
going to take this stuff but I do not
want any of you to read my emails okay
so I chat with my friends okay or I
actually send emails do everything I
want and then end of day what I do is I
go click log out sigh note this is the
normal process correct okay now tell me
if I not run any proteins or bad goes
anything in my computer there are highly
chances that I would not be able to gain
access to the password correct a
username password but I will tell you
there are other techniques in which an
attacker can gain access to the password
let me show you how all right I have a
just downloaded all three pins in okay
okay so this application it is freely
downloadable it is available at cheat
engine dot o-r-g you can check out the
site www.cnn.com it for you okay now
cheat engine is a application that you
can install after everything you know
after a person logs and logs out
everything then also you can get this
software install and once that is
installed you can see this I can here
glowing correct I go okay when I click
on this it shows various application
that is currently running on my computer
okay so now I will select chrome because
I know that it is a Chrome browser right
so I'll select chrome I'll say open
right step 1
all right step 1 I actually open the
running process number 2 I say pass what
am I gonna cert I'm gonna search for
password right so I say pass step 3
I say first scan once this n is done
which means that I am searching for this
variable pass rate so I am going to
click memory boo look at this memory
view very interesting this memory view
is actually going to show us the memory
from the M let me search what was my
nail or let me quickly type my password
ie I think this is likely in the
password look at this
I want you all to pay attention look at
this this clearly tells this is the
username that I died and this is the
password right let me search it instead
of typing the password to search I will
type my username self okay see if it
really gives away information saying
this is the username this is the
password right are you able to
understand so what we did was we
actually used a application called sheet
engine
alright cheat engine there is a hex
viewer application all right hex viewer
application
so with this hex viewer we opened up the
memory of the computer's RAM and load up
our currently running process which is
the Chrome application and try to open
up the memory and see the username and
password as simple as that correct I'm
sure you are all able to follow if you
want I'm just going to repeat that for
our advantage once again all right
ok I'll close this once again
okay so I go to gmail.com
in gmail.com say I type in my this is my
email address and saying my password I'm
saying
qwe rty one two three four five six
assume this is the password that I have
type in okay obviously have typed in the
wrong password because I do not want you
all to see that right so this data all
right
this data is what I want to capture from
the hex viewer right so what I do is I
open up the hex view cheat engine right
and what I do I click on this and in
exchange gonna see us say first scan
here I'm gonna click memory view and I'm
actually opening up the memory here I
say search memory for what does that
know right
so I said you know okay so there is
another instance of you know okay this
is another instance of you know okay
okay now it very clearly gives us a
information that the username type in
the email addresses this right if you
can clearly see it says email s we know
the percentage for T is at the rate
right person wait for T so we know that
in physical thumb and password this qwe
RT y one two three four five six today
so we successfully able to read the
gmail password right off the memory and
please do remember whatever you are
seeing is a HTTP page so it has got
nothing to do with the traffic
encryption or decryption out happening
here
we read everything of them memory all
right so with this I would want to
compute the session today I hope that
you all had a wonderful time learning in
case you have any questions I'd be more
than happy to address so I would be
available on the chat any questions
please do post it I'd be more than happy
to address thank you very much have a
wonderful evening
I'll be available for some more time in
case you have questions please do post
it
you